I'm pulmonologist Dr Ravi Calhan let's
answer some questions from Twitter this
is lung support
[Music]
Jay wisen asks if you vape what your
lungs look like quick normally a lung
looks like this there's a black which is
air inside the lung and it looks really
clear so if you vape and you are unlucky
and get vaping Associated lung injury
inflammation happens and the air sacs
fill up with stuff so this white stuff
in this x-ray really is the injury
caused by vaping so this means there's
fluid inside the air sacs you can't move
oxygen and carbon dioxide through fluid
they're gases it makes it hard to
breathe because the air can't move in
and out of your lungs and exchange the
oxygen for carbon dioxide at gvybi asks
how do lungs know what's oxygen and
what's carbon dioxide so the lungs don't
know what's oxygen and carbon dioxide
the air comes in through the windpipe
gets spread out throughout the lung in a
bunch of air sacs each air sac has a
blood vessel going by it so the gas
moves from inside the air sacs in the
lung into the blood where it attaches to
hemoglobin that's job is to carry oxygen
it's really AVID for oxygen and then the
carbon dioxide Which is higher in the
blood than it is in the air that's
inside the lung diffuses out at Harris
A1 asks can lungs be transplanted they
sure can lung transplants are done
mostly for chronic lung diseases like
pulmonary fibrosis cystic fibrosis or
COPD chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease to get a lung transplant you
have to go on a bypass machine and then
they actually remove a lung cutting off
the windpipe and reattaching the
windpipe and put in a new set of lungs
but you got to be pretty pretty sick to
get a lung transplant at Neiman Marcus
Esq asks I wonder what bad lungs sound
like I'm in the doctor's office with
good sounding lungs
know how bad lungs sound when you go to
the doctor they put on their stethoscope
and they you know very doctorally start
listening in the back side to side
bottom when we say lungs sound good that
means we can hear air moving in and out
of the lungs without making any extra
noises one of the most common things we
hear is wheezing sounds like this
[Music]
that Whistling noise on the way out
means that there's resistance to air
moving through the windpipes we hear
this sound wheezing pretty commonly with
asthma sometimes with COPD because of
narrowing of the windpipes people can
wheeze another thing we listen for is
crackles they sound like this
[Music]
crackles occur when there's stuff in the
air sacs so if there's fluid in the air
sacs it creates a crackling noise when
it inflates that can be created by heart
failure blood backing up into the lungs
from the heart because the heart isn't
pumping well it can be created by
pneumonia when fluid fills up areas of
the lung and those are usually what we
call fine crackles there also can be
something called coarse crackles
oh
coarse crackles occur when there's
pulmonary fibrosis or scarring in the
lungs at UC you me asks honestly WTF is
COPD like what COPD is the most common
lung disease it occurs mostly in smokers
and it sometimes gets called emphysema
the lung is normally rubbery and elastic
it's like made up of tons of balloons
and if you take a balloon and you blow
air into it
and when you take the air and let go so
air fills the lung it comes out super
easily and fast with emphysema the lung
loses its elasticity so it gets like
this grocery bag air can go into it
and then someone has to breathe in again
because you got to keep breathing right
so more air goes in and then it just
stays there and then more air goes in
and it just stays there imagine taking a
breath in
and then taking another breath in and
then taking another breath in without
air coming out fully after each breath
and then getting up and trying to like
go up a flight of stairs it's pretty
uncomfortable to move around with air
stuck in your lungs at art sets you free
asks how much snot can your lungs hold
the lung capacity like the amount of
volume in someone's lungs can be
anywhere from three to five liters mucus
is produced by the cells that line the
windpipes if someone has allergies right
and they inhale a bunch of pollen their
nose starts running and dripping and
their lungs can produce stuff and they
start coughing and to protect against
that reaction it creates fluid or a film
along the lining of the lungs so that
the exposure to that stuff goes down at
Blast bottle asks does anyone have
studies of hashtag cannabis inhalations
effect on the lungs trying to gauge
long-term damage how it compares to
smoking cigarettes and whether vaping
really reduces risk it's been known for
some time that smoking marijuana causes
less injury to the lungs than smoking
tobacco cigarettes people smoke fewer
joints historically than they do
cigarettes in a day it's also true that
marijuana itself is what we call a
bronchodilator so it relaxes the muscle
in the windpipes and opens them up a
little bit so people temporarily can
breathe easier if they get cannabis in
their lungs now the problem is Vape
juice doesn't just have pure cannabis in
it it has all sorts of other things and
you heat it up and it causes long-term
problems because all the other stuff
gets in the lungs and causes damage to
the windpipes and air sacs at cattle
golf asks I've been thinking about
alveoli too much lately I just want to
know what they feel like are they soft
like Roe or is there firmness like a
ripe Berry I think maybe the best way to
think about the lung is like a sponge
not really firm like a raspberry the
lung has a main branch that's this y
here and then it branches into millions
of tiny branches at the end of each
branch is a tiny air sac called an
alveolus then the whole thing is
surrounded by like a Saran Wrap called
the pora which holds the whole thing
together that Jinx after asks why is
cold air so hard on lungs well cold air
triggers reactions in things right it's
hard on skin it makes your eyes water
you breathe in cold air hits your
windpipes can really irritate them in
people with asthma it can cause an
asthma flare-up it can cause wheezing
and real trouble breathing so what
should people do about that well
breathing through your nose is better
than breathing through your mouth when
you breathe through your nose the air
gets warmed up and humidified before
where it goes into the lungs or when
it's really cold people especially with
asthma but probably everybody who gets
sensitive to cold air should wear a
scarf or a mask or something that allows
the air to get warmed before they
breathe in at Emily cblz asks how do I I
train my lungs to not asthma you can't
really train your lungs to not have
asthma you can avoid the things that
trigger your asthma so if you're
allergic to cats get rid of your cat so
when asthma is acting up there's
inflammation inside the windpipes and
when there's inflammation inside the
windpipes they get narrowed and filled
up with mucus and phlegm so air can't
move in and out and then the muscles
around the windpipe actually spasm and
squeeze the windpipe shut so the best
way to deal with asthma is to use an
inhaled anti-inflammatory medicine a lot
of people have asthma 10 to 15 percent
of people in the United States have
asthma their inhaler may have a
bronchodilator something called
albuterol a rescue medicine that opens
up their windpipes most people with
asthma who have significant symptoms
should be on an anti-inflammatory
inhaler and inhaled corticosteroid which
lowers the inflammation so they don't
need this rescue bronchodilator at
Alexander McCoy 4S is there any truth to
the urban legend that smokers do better
than non-smokers in high altitude rocks
because their lungs are used to it there
is no truth to that smokers do not do
better at altitude in fact a lot to do
worse because they might have COPD or
other things that impair their oxygen in
their lungs there's lower oxygen
pressure at higher altitudes which means
there's less oxygen available to
transfer the lungs one of the
adaptations that the body makes after
it's been at high altitude is to make
more hemoglobin the oxygen carrying
capacity of the blood goes up athletes
sometimes train at high altitude to
improve their hemoglobin so that they
are capable of carrying more oxygen when
they are at sea level at yoyo Yelena
asks curious what does covid do to lungs
does it fill them with fluid the x-rays
look horrible but I have no clue what
they mean when covid was causing the
pandemic and people were dying
everywhere it caused pneumonia so this
is what coven can look like in the lung
this one has worse pneumonia on the left
side and not as bad on the right side
this area right here this white stuff
it's filled up socked in we call it
consolidation has bacteria immune cells
white blood cells things that are trying
to fight an infection I bet you this
person got really sick had a low blood
oxygen level and was having a really
hard time breathing why some people with
covid caught a runny nose and other
people got pneumonia and died we don't
know some people are just more
vulnerable like if you have diabetes if
you smoke cigarettes or vape you're
probably more vulnerable to infections
at water cooler asks how does a pulse
oximeter measure the blood oxygen levels
without actually taking blood so this
pulse oximeter you can wear on your
finger shoots infrared light from one
side and has a sensor on the other and
you got to put it on a part of thin skin
that's why we put it on our finger or
earlobe hemoglobin when it has oxygen
attached to it has a certain
configuration and when it doesn't have
oxygen attached to it has a different
configuration that influences how much
light gets absorbed and then the sensor
in the pulse oximeter can then calculate
how much blood oxygen there is based on
that confirmation of hemoglobin a normal
blood oxygen level is like 95 or higher
it's dangerous if it's below 90 that's
when I think we should really pay
attention at hirojima asks I'm sorry but
how is mouth-to-mouth even real like how
am I not just exhaling carbon dioxide
into your lungs instantly killing you
scientists explain this so it's not
mainly carbon dioxide what we breathe in
remember is mostly nitrogen the
atmosphere is mostly made up of nitrogen
at about 21 oxygen and then some small
portion of carbon dioxide so when you
breathe out there's a little more carbon
dioxide than what's in the air but it's
not a hundred percent carbon dioxide
it's still more like the air we breathe
in than anything else at Paisley Mott's
ass like do lungs have muscles can I
train myself to be like able to hold my
breath longer than anyone the diaphragm
is outside the lung it goes downward the
lung opens up so those muscles can be
trained and you can make those muscles
stronger and breathe more efficiently to
some extent but but the lungs themselves
don't have muscles that generate
breathing one of the reasons people who
train can hold their breath longer is
they're in better shape all their
muscles in their body demand less oxygen
and produce less carbon dioxide so their
lungs don't have to do as much work to
keep those muscles fueled sometimes
people who have operations are in the
hospital get a gadget called an
incentive spirometer where you're told
to breathe in and make these balls go up
the reason for that is people who are
lying in bed don't breathe deeply and
then if that happens areas of the lung
can end up without air in them called
atelectasis and we want to prevent that
because Aries of the lung without air in
them are prone to developing pneumonia
and one of the ways we prevent that is
forcing people to breathe deeply using
one of these machines at BPH Esq asks
which is worse for your lungs vaping or
smoking hashtag asking for several
friends smoking we've known forever to
be bad and vaping is newer and we don't
know how bad but I'm a lung doctor so I
think inhaling anything but air is bad
for your lungs the lungs can recover
from some injuries the things that are
caused by the environment like smoking
cigarettes causing COPD or emphysema or
pulmonary fibrosis which is scarring in
the lungs those things don't heal we
have treatments that stop them from
getting worse but we don't have a way to
just fix it and make it act like you
were never exposed to that problem and
the lung never got damaged in the first
place and I was right once asks why TF
do lungs have an uneven number of lobes
what's up with that well the reason is
is that the left lung has to make space
for the heart because the heart sits in
the left side of the chest there are
three lobes on the right upper middle
lower and two lobes on the left
as lung cancer happen only because of
smoking lung Cancer's most common cause
is smoking but there are a lot of people
who don't smoke who get lung cancer
there's one exposure that's well known
to cause lung cancer and that's radon
exposure around the country people's
basements can have a lot of radon and
home tests are available to test for
Radon and radon is clearly associated
with lung cancer when it's present in
someone's house a lot of young women
seem to get lung cancer who didn't smoke
we have no idea why that is they get a
type of lung cancer that's often called
an adenocarcinoma or maybe they had
secondhand smoke exposure in the home
maybe there's a genetic Factor but it's
pretty scary that non-smokers still get
lung cancer at a pretty significant rate
and
she asks how long before
the automated tools on CAT scans are
coming soon and will be really helpful
one of the things where I think they'll
be super helpful are the things we can't
see you know a CAT scan is a picture and
it has various densities of images and
we can't see every density on a CAT scan
but there might be parts of the lung
that are starting to have abnormalities
that we can't see visually that a
machine could detect and in that sense
AI would be huge right and figure out
whether that person needs some enhanced
surveillance or things to keep an eye on
to see whether they get cancer at
though asks how to ta1's collapse do
they just get tired or something
hired you usually they get injured and
it causes the lung to collapse and
causes what we call a pneumothorax
getting stabbed or shot or having
something go through the chest wall can
puncture the lungs so there's two sets
of poor there's a layer of Saran Wrap
that's holding all those alveoli
together and then there's a layer
against the chest wall and there's a
space between the lungs and the rib cage
if you pop the balloon poke a hole in
the Saran Wrap air can escape from
inside the lung to outside of the lung
that builds pressure and the lung can
collapse it doesn't have enough pressure
inside the lung to stay open so it
deflates so those are all the questions
for today lots of good ones thanks for
watching lung support
[Music]